willkommen ein spiel wie wahrheit oder
pflicht war ohne die wahrheit
lottozahlen um zuzusehen player spielen
um geld und ruhm zu gewinnen bist du
roger oder player is the water oder
player bist du water oder flash player
mein name ist herzlich willkommen wir
heute zu einem neuen video ich befinde
mich in dem ich gerade mit max zusammen
berlin für die letzten elf talent
übrigens einmal dank an euch dass ihr so
oft den hashtag gesperrt hat überall in
den kommentaren dass wir ins finale
kommen durften
was machen wir genau hier in berlin wir
lassen wie beim eigentlich immer so den
den tag über challenges auf uns zukommen
und heute ist der letzte tag das heißt
es wird richtig krass das ist heldt
schon challenge bekommen begebt euch aus
hotel das natürlich nicht schlimm oder
hotel davor das ausdrücken ja niemand
will ja gut ist angenommen bekommt
hatten damals aus normal
ich weiß nicht ob nicht seine höhenangst
bericht aber ich habe übrigens eine
respektvolle höhere alter schwede
sie können kreis verkürzte gehörte
göttergatte
stellt euch eure angst 30 minuten
angenommen weil unser angst hat dass mit
ihr zu tun
vermutlich ein bisschen angst nicht
unter schock
rutsche schon noch weiter mein gott
bleibt die ganze härte druck mal bitte
deine beine richtig so ist's richtig
durch das hat mir das ding durch die
route nach links ich hab ihn nur auf dem
linken einiger alter ich stehe nur auf
dem linken bein gab plötzlich hoch dass
nicht auch ohne spaß mich dass mein gott
als normal
richtig durchdrücken können durch glaube
ich habe nichts anfangen
als ich dich schon wieder nach links ich
gehe ja längst
es geht nicht es geht ja um das gerät
ist
[Musik]
egal
es ist sowas da drüben ist der
alexanderplatz entfernt sie zu
[Musik]
halte ich bin ich hab's nicht gemacht
und fertig ist fraglich es ist ja es war
echt krass aber möglich nur die schränke
wir haben die leute auch gesagt da oben
ja das schlimmste ist dieser stift über
diese ganze den habe ich jetzt zwei mal
gemacht aber für mich was ich wollte
nicht festhalten weil ich sonst völlig
runter ja das ist er ist er ganz perplex
beschreiben wir haben sie bestanden
springt vom park inn und schließlich
größer ist nicht mal anschauen eine
[Musik]
begleichen
ich gehe damit die hoffnung ich gucke
mir gerne die aussichten an aber was hat
dich hätte ich ja vom party im springen
[Musik]
näher kommen angenommen es uns mal an
ich kann nicht sagen dass ich nach dem
diesmal aber lasst uns mal anschauen
anschauen dann schauen uns alles an ich
ging dann nicht runter
[Musik]
komplett da allein mein gott du kriegst
du bringst du bringst zurück ich bin
gerade eben 1 70 meter jetzt sind wir
gerade auf 140 meter
wir aber gehen wir mal was man da
vorgehen das weitere vorgehen
hier wo wir gleich hingehen sollte
runterspringen ich schaue dass das mal
an der da vorne ist ja alex und der hat
jetzt gerade wirklich noch höher als wir
alles andere wie gerade unter und es ist
dort besucht wie das haus fahren gerade
ich würde sagen die challenge freundes
ende
ich finde die wirtschaft könnte ja mal
weniger zentrum film
mein kurz stetiger niemals mache ich das
oh gott oh gott
jetzt ist er unten niemals mache ich das
ich kann das ich habe keine worte ich
finde keine worte ich kann das nicht
machen
bis das hochhaus zum ihr seht das
vielleicht hat nicht so richtig aber
schaut euch das mal an junge stehen wir
vor hengst da jetzt so mit den armen
ausgestreckt dann wieder roger
alter schwede freunde schaut euch das an
ja das 90 quasi die letzte läuft
challenge wir haben es nicht geschafft
in der vorerst wieder für uns als team
gelöst
das war es danke dass ihr uns über den
hashtag ins finale gebracht habe der
film ist schon in den kinos der ist am
donnerstag in die kinos gekommen
danke dass ihr euch das video angeschaut
habe ich würde sagen an der stelle
schluss mit neffe uns ja schluss mit dem
video war echt cool
wir sehen uns mit das war es jetzt ihr
vom video meine damen und herren wir
hoffen dass hat euch gefallen wir uns
das getan hat las
falls ihr noch nicht genug kriegen
können von jörg hier findet ihr einmal
wieder von kelly mal wanne verlinkt und
hier kommt bald noch ein video von k s
in kraft für uns war es heute sehr
emotional aber und würde ich sagen
macht's gut